¿qué pasa si resulta que hay un
continente entre aquí y Japón, hacia donde estás navegando?
¿Cuáles serán las consecuencias para la humanidad
si resulta ser ese el caso?"
Creo que Colón quizá respondería
que tal vez no puedas entender, pero probablemente
no hubiera sido correcta, y creo que predecir
lo que significará el hallazgo de E.T.,
tampoco podemos hacerlo.
Pero aquí hay un par de cosas que puedo decir.
Para empezar, va a ser una sociedad más avanzada que la nuestra.
No vas a oír de aliens de Neandertal.
No están construyendo transmisores.
Van a estar por delante de nosotros, tal vez por unos pocos miles
de años, tal vez por unos pocos millones años, pero sustancialmente
por delante de nosotros y eso significa que, si podemos entender
cualquier cosa que vayan a decir, entonces podríamos tomar
un atajo en la historia obteniendo información de una sociedad
que está mucho más allá que la nuestra.
Ahora, esto podría parecernos algo hiperbólico, y puede que lo sea,
pero sin embargo, es concebible que esto sucederá,
y, saben, podría considerarse esto como, no sé,
dar a Julio César, clases de inglés y la clave
para acceder a la biblioteca del Congreso.
¿Cambiaría su día, verdad?
Esta es una cosa. Otra cosa que seguro
va a suceder es que nos pondrá en perspectiva.
Sabremos que no somos ese milagro, correcto,
que solo somos un pato de la fila,
no somos los únicos de la cuadra, y creo que eso
filosóficamente es algo muy profundo para aprender.
¿No somos un milagro, está bien?
La tercera cosa que les podría decir es algo vaga,
pero me parece interesante e importante,
y es que, si encontráramos una señal proveniente de una
sociedad más avanzada, puesto que lo serán,
nos dirá algo sobre nuestras propias posibilidades,
que no estamos inevitablemente condenados a la autodestrucción.
Puesto que ellos sobrevivieron su tecnología,
nosotros también podríamos hacerlo.
Normalmente cuando miramos hacia el Universo,
estamos mirando hacia atrás en el tiempo. ¿sí?
Es interesante para los cosmólogos.
Pero en este sentido, realmente se puede mirar hacia el futuro,
vagamente, pero se puede mirar hacia el futuro.
Así que esas son todos los tipos de cosas que provendrían de una detección.
Ahora, permítanme hablar un poco de algo que ocurre
incluso en el ínterin, y es que,
SETI, creo que es importante, ya que es exploración, y
no solo exploración, es exploración comprensible.
Ahora, tengo que decirles, que siempre estoy leyendo libros sobre
exploradores. La exploración me resulta muy interesante,
La exploración del Ártico, saben, gente como Magallanes,
Amundsen, Shackleton, ven a Franklin allí abajo,
Scott, todos estos chicos. Es realmente ingeniosa, la exploración.
Y lo hacen sólo porque quieren explorar,
y podríamos decir: "Oh, esa es una especie de oportunidad frívola",
pero no es frívolo. No es una actividad frívola,
porque, quiero decir, pensemos en las hormigas.
La mayoría de las hormigas están programadas para seguirse una a la otra
a lo largo de una larga línea, pero hay algunas hormigas,
tal vez el uno por ciento de las hormigas, que son lo que se puede llamar
hormigas pioneras y son las que deambulan.
Son las que encontramos en la mesada de la cocina.
Hay que darles con el pulgar antes que
encuentren el azúcar u otra cosa.
Pero esas hormigas, aunque la mayoría sean eliminadas,
esas son las hormigas que son esenciales para la supervivencia
del hormiguero. Entonces la exploración es importante.
También creo que la exploración es importante en términos de
poder abordar lo que pienso que es una falta
crítica en nuestra sociedad y es la falta de divulgación de la ciencia,
la falta de capacidad de entender siquiera la ciencia.
Ahora, miren, mucho se ha escrito sobre el
estado deplorable de la educación científica en este país.
Lo han escuchado.
Bien, de hecho, aquí hay un ejemplo.
Se hicieron encuestas, esta se realizó hace 10 años.
Muestra que aproximadamente un tercio del público piensa
que los extraterrestres no solo están ahí fuera, los estamos buscando
ahí fuera, sino que están aquí, ¿verdad?
Navegando los cielos en sus platillos y en ocasiones
secuestrando personas para experimentos que sus padres no aprobarían.
Bueno, eso sería interesante si fuera cierto,
y seguridad laboral para mí, pero no creo que la evidencia sea
muy buena. Esto es más triste que significativo.
Pero hay otras cosas que la gente cree
que son significativas, como la eficacia de la homeopatía,
o que la evolución es una especie de idea loca
de científicos sin piernas, o que la evolución...
todo ese tipo de cosas, o el calentamiento global.
Ese tipo de ideas realmente no tienen ninguna validez,
que no se pueda confiar en los científicos.
Ahora, tenemos que resolver ese problema, porque es
un problema muy importante y podríamos decir:
"Bueno, está bien, ¿cómo vamos a resolver ese problema con SETI?"
Bueno, quisiera sugerirles que obviamente SETI no puede
resolver el problema, pero que puede abordar el problema.
Puede abordar el problema consiguiendo que los jóvenes
se interesen en la ciencia. Miren, la ciencia es difícil,
tiene una reputación de ser difícil, y en realidad es difícil,
y ese es el resultado de 400 años de ciencia, ¿no?
Es decir, en el siglo XVIII,
podríamos llegar a ser un experto en cualquier campo de la ciencia
en una tarde yendo a una biblioteca,
si pudiéramos encontrar la biblioteca, ¿no?
En el siglo XIX, si tuviéramos un laboratorio en el sótano,
podríamos hacer grandes descubrimientos científicos
en nuestra propia casa. ¿Verdad? Debido a que todo aquello era
ciencia tirada por ahí esperando a alguien la recogiera.
Ahora, eso ya no es cierto.
Hoy en día, hay que pasar varios años en la escuela de posgrado
y haciendo post-doctorado sólo para averiguar cuáles
son las cuestiones importantes.
Es difícil. No hay ninguna duda.
Y, de hecho, aquí hay un ejemplo: el bosón de Higgs,
encontrar el bosón de Higgs.
Pregúntenle a 10 personas cercanas que vean en la calle:
"Oye, ¿crees que vale la pena gastar miles de millones
de francos suizos buscando el bosón de Higgs?"
Y apuesto que la respuesta que van a obtener es:
"Bueno, no sé qué es el bosón de Higgs,
y no sé si es importante".
Y probablemente la mayoría de las personas ni siguiera sabrían
el valor de un franco suizo, ¿sí?
Y sin embargo estamos gastando miles de millones de francos suizos en este problema.
¿De acuerdo? Así que la gente no se interesa en la ciencia
debido a que no pueden comprender de qué se trata.
SETI, por otro lado, es realmente simple.
Vamos a usar estas antenas grandes
y a tratar de interceptar las señales. Todo el mundo puede entender eso.
Sí, tecnológicamente, es muy sofisticado,
pero todo el mundo comprende la idea.
Así que eso es una cosa. La otra cosa es que es una ciencia apasionante.
Es emocionante porque estamos naturalmente interesados
en otros seres inteligentes y creo que eso es
parte de nuestro cableado.
Es decir, estamos programados para estar interesados
en seres que podrían ser, si se quiere, competidores,
o si eres romántico, posiblemente incluso compañeros. ¿sí?
Es decir, esto es análogo a nuestro interés en las cosas que
tienen dientes grandes. ¿Correcto?
Estamos interesados en cosas que tienen dientes grandes
y podemos ver el valor evolutivo de eso, y también podemos ver
las consecuencias prácticas viendo "Animal Planet".
Notarán que hacen muy pocos programas sobre jerbos.
Mayormente los hacen sobre cosas que tienen dientes grandes.
Muy bien, así que estamos interesados en este tipo de cosas.
Y no sólo nosotros. También los niños.
Esto nos permite devolver el favor mediante el uso de este tema como
un gancho para la ciencia, porque SETI implica todo tipo de ciencia,
obviamente biología, obviamente astronomía,
pero también geología, química, varias disciplinas
científicas que pueden presentarse en la forma de:
"Estamos buscando E.T.".
Entonces para mí es interesante e importante y, de hecho,
es mi política y aunque dé muchas charlas para adultos,
dos días después vuelven a donde estaban.
Pero si se da charlas a los niños, saben,
en uno de cada 50 de ellos, alguna bombilla se activa, y piensan:
"Vaya, nunca había pensado que", y luego se van
a leer un libro o una revista o lo que sea.
Se interesan en algo.
Ahora es mi teoría, apoyada solo por anécdotas,
anécdotas personales pero, no obstante,
estos niños logran interesarse en algo entre
los 8 y los 11 años. Tienes que llegarles ahí.
Entonces, doy charlas para adultos, lo que está muy bien, pero trato de hacer
un 10 % de las charlas que doy,
para los chicos.
Recuerdo cuando un hombre vino a nuestra escuela secundaria, en realidad,
era mi escuela primaria. Yo estaba en sexto grado.
Y nos dio una charla. Todo lo que recuerdo de ella
es una palabra: electrónica.
Era como Dustin Hoffman en "El graduado",
cuando dijo "plástica", lo que quiera que signifique, plástica.
Bien, el tipo dijo electrónica. No recuerdo
nada más. De hecho, no recuerdo nada
de lo que mi maestra de sexto grado dijo durante todo el año,
pero recuerdo "electrónica".
Y de esa manera me interesé en la electrónica
y estudié para obtener mi licencia de radioaficionado. Yo estaba cableando cosas.
Aquí estoy yo a eso de los 15, haciendo ese tipo de cosas.
¿De acuerdo? Eso tuvo un gran efecto en mí.
Esa es mi idea, que se puede causar un gran efecto
en estos niños.
De hecho, esto me recuerda, no sé, hace un par de años
di una charla en una escuela de Palo Alto
donde había una docena de niños de 11 años
que habían asistido a la charla.
Me convocaron para hablarles durante una hora.
Once años de edad, todos sentados en semicírculo
mirándome con ojos grandes, y comencé,
había un pizarrón blanco detrás de mí, y empecé
escribiendo un 1 seguido de 22 ceros, y dije:
"Bien, miren, este es el número de estrellas
en el universo visible, y este número es tan grande
que ni siquiera hay un nombre para él".
Uno de estos niños levantó su mano y dijo:
"Bueno, realmente hay un nombre para él.
Es un sextra-cuadra-hexa o algo así".
Ahora, ese niño se equivocó en cuatro órdenes de magnitud,
pero no cabe ninguna duda, estos niños eran inteligentes.
Así que dejé de dar la Conferencia.
Todo lo que querían era hacer preguntas.
De hecho, mis último comentarios a estos niños, al final dije:
"Saben chicos, Uds. son más inteligentes
que la gente con la que trabajo". Ahora... (Risas)
Ni siquiera les importó.
Lo que querían era mi dirección de correo electrónico
para poder hacerme más preguntas. (Risas)
Permítanme decirles que mi trabajo es un privilegio
porque estamos en una época especial.
Las generaciones anteriores no pudieron de ninguna manera hacer este experimento.
En una generación más,
creo que vamos a tener éxito.
Así que para mí, es un privilegio, y cuando me miro en el espejo,
realmente no me veo a mí mismo.
Lo que veo es la generación que viene detrás de mí.
Estos son algunos niños de la escuela de Huff, alumnos de cuarto grado.
Hablé allí, hace dos semanas, más o menos.
Creo que si se puede inculcar cierto interés por la ciencia
y cómo funciona, bien, eso es una recompensa
más allá de toda medida. Muchas gracias.
(Aplausos)